little shrimp ah okay
rethink that move son i hate him anna's
face garbage
why don't you just tell him to stop
shaving at his desk he denies even doing
it i don't know why
next time i catch him shaving i'm gonna
punch him so hard in the mouth he bites
his own heart
could that be why he denies doing it oh
yeah you could be right yeah
i don't like loud noises and people
making a fuss
and i especially don't like people
celebrating because they know a piece of
private information
about me plus the whole thing is a scam
birthdays were invented by hallmark to
sell cards
i know you don't like anyone wishing you
a happy birthday so
crappy day to you still too much i
assume you're not doing anything to
celebrate tonight
anyone over the age of six celebrating a
birthday should go to hell come on
everybody let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming great
attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something i
can disable the security dvrs but i need
some way of getting to a station
unnoticed
i have an idea on how to smuggle you in
but it'll be a tight fit i'm flexible i
do a lot of yoga
you do yoga helps keep me centered and
if you ask me about it again i'll hunt
you down and rip your face off
okay great good plan one time when i
skateboard this story's awesome
indeed thank you for sharing jenny
ann was getting a little chummy when
people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them
that's a genius move thank you you're
welcome
lester
morning oh i can't believe you live
nearby and you won't let anyone crash at
your place
you people already know too much about
me i know exactly three facts about you
and one of them is that you won't let
any of us crash at your place
i am only here because i owe leslie a
thousand favors
i'm not big on charities give a man a
fish
and you feed him for a day don't teach a
man to fish
and you feed yourself he's a grown man
fishing's not that hard what the hell
were you thinking you're lucky you just
dislocated your knee how do you know
it's
located i went to med school for three
years you did win let me take you there
and you can talk to the salesperson
counteroffer you take me nowhere and i
talk to no one counter counteroffer you
come with me
or i make you attend a four-hour fax
cover sheet protocol meeting either way
it's a win for me
why are you being such a gloomy guest
i'm a realistic randy didn't go with
rosa huh
i'm gonna have to meet a whole new group
of people i hate people
life sucks nothing good ever happens
jean-ralphio
big t mr swanson two things
one it is an absolute honor to meet you
two who is that hot intern chick out
there because honestly damn
uh take a seat right here we go so
jean ralphio you got him right here
leave a message after the beat
why do i want you as my assistant for
starters
access to the illest clubs and that's
just for starters i will work for you
i'll be on you 24 7. i'll be like your
family i'm here when you get here in the
morning sure enough i'll be there
tucking into bed at night don't worry
it's not gay do we have questions
i think our only question is uh when can
you start right now let's do it
thank you for coming in we will talk
cool i feel good about this i know you
can hit me up on facebook any time day
or night you know that right
take care buddy boom so what do you
think of your new assistant
i want to punch you in the face so bad
right now what
it's my birthday i hate birthdays if you
wish me a happy birthday i will punch
you
you're a funny little bird diaz happy
birthday ron swanson
just the man i wanted to see i'm going
to be going to a
seminar on the art of the japanese tea
ceremony or
chicago at the pawnee community college
and i thought you might like to come
with me why
i know how much you value silence a fair
point
but we did just have lunch last week so
i feel like we've spent enough social
time together
for the foreseeable effort we should be
happier we found the jewels we won
yeah you're right we should celebrate
why don't we go to a bar and drink in
silence
cool sounds good no i was being a [ __ ]
how did you not pick up on that
what is your problem man this is about
your stupid anniversary present yeah
that
and you not telling me about marcus
we're supposed to be friends sound like
sauron or agneta whichever the boy one
is
well say what you want about them at
least they communicate you know i've
never even heard your slam poetry rosa
why do you all of a sudden care about
every single little detail in my life
because all we talk about is cop stuff
all right and that was fine when we were
20 cause that's all i cared about but
we're adults now and there are other
things
like me and amy and you and marcus that
friends are supposed to talk about well
i guess we're not friends then
wow i don't want to seem overdramatic
but
this is literally a battle for april's
soul i don't want to seem overdramatic
but i don't really care what happens
here should i get amy something
cash like shot glasses or something less
cash like
golden shot glasses still don't care
excuse me
there's a sign at ramps at park that
says do not drink the sprinkler water
so i made sun tea with it and now i have
an infection
sir sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
hey diaz right the walls
can i help you i need the crime stats
from last month fine
one sec so basically
we're completely swamped all hands on
deck i don't even work in this building
don't care i need anyone with a pulse
and a brain to pitch in
ron do you need help with anything no
we're good thanks
in fact you can head home early the guy
who did the safe in the second apartment
what's his name
cohn seasoned captain always in
overlooked what nothing she said she
isn't captain always
yeah i know how to spell comb okay
whoa i am pretty sure you shouldn't have
a weapon at work
literally everything is a weapon son
that folder
in my hands is far deadlier than this
bow in yours
oh that's probably true if someone broke
into your apartment and you weren't cops
wouldn't you be scared yes
depends how many guns do i still have
hidden no
do i stole my knife nunchucks
axe it was a hypothetical question i
know but i want to play it out
do i solve my throwing stars this has
taken a strange turn
look i love a good dog as much as the
next guy but this building doesn't allow
animals
andy take him outside and shoot him no
just keep him outside oh come on ron
i'm just a little puppy i ain't doing
nothing wrong
i'm just a puppy i like your mustache
i wish i could have one but i but i'm
just a little bubbly
okay take him out and shoot him
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill
everyone in this room and then myself
why are we here
i just thought you needed some fresh air
even if that air is filled with the foul
stench of european socialism
we thought the shipping container came
in on october 11th 1011 but dumb
europeans write their dates backwards
we should have been going for the one
from 10 no found off of course stupid
rest of the world writing their date all
dumb
yeah let's go okay your house isn't
haunted you're lonely
is anything even real no odds are we
exist in a computer simulation but i
don't have time to go down that rabbit
hole
ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes
plenty no you need to drink
water usually i take it neat but i will
make an exception in the name of health
last night i watched a movie with diane
and the girls
in which an orange fish is separated
from his father
the children were sniffling which i
believe to be due to the sad nature of
the film
i was wrong you need to take off those
layers rehydrate and go to the doctor
thank you for your concern i will be
fine
please turn the thermostat up to 90 and
leave me alone ron this isn't safe
i am a grown man i have had a cold
before
i need no help so if you don't
mind
that seems about right everything okay
with diaz
yeah she fell asleep five minutes after
i locked her in and she hasn't moved in
the past 10
hours she talks in her sleep i'm gonna
rip your head off
i'm gonna rip your damn head off grandma
oh terra bear what if she sleeps forever
you